well hi everybody this is Sam with
Python basics and I just want to welcome
you all to a first of many python
tutorial live streams so we're gonna do
two hours today so locally for me it's
9:00 and it's 10:00 Eastern and we're
gonna go for two hours so the idea of
this is this is for a complete beginner
so we're actually just gonna act like we
don't even have Python on our computers
so we need to go to Python org look up
here at downloads and as you see right
here you can download three point eight
point one when we look at mine I have
three excuse me three eight three I have
three eight one so you come down here
you click this save and it's going to
install down here in the bottom corner I
got mine kind of zoomed in a little bit
and then we'll go ahead and open this up
but if you're new to Python it is a very
high-level language and I'm sure you
guys have already seen in the comments
that Python slow and things like this
but one of the things that I love about
it that I believe makes it such a very
powerful language is the amount of
contributors and the community and as
many people that are involved because it
actually started out as a community
language so alright you can just hit
right now it's gonna ask me but you hit
the install right here and now there's
gonna be a checkbox down here in the
bottom and it's to install the path I
recommend
ahead and do that right now but let's
just assume that you guys already have
that I want to cancel this so now this
is the shell and you might hear me also
call this idle and just so it's what the
integrated development environment idle
you might have an editor but right now
everything that we're gonna be doing
today and for a while you are not going
to need an editor all that you're going
all that you're gonna need is the shell
so let's just go ahead and jump into it
so in Python there are four types of
variables you have integers floats
strings and boolean s-- so let's just
let's just go ahead and get started so
and like I was saying my name is Sam and
then float is anything with a decimal
and let's see true so you got you got
your integer you got your string you got
your float and you have your boolean so
now now we need to kind of understand
what these do so what what computers are
awesome at is repeatability and
remembering things so right here we're
storing things in memory so we don't
have to remember any of this now let's
go ahead and look at some of the very
powerful things that Python already has
for us these are the methods that are
associated with this type variable and
we can look at this so now one like I
said
Python is very powerful because of the
community so now there are built-in
functions already defined for us so I
used der right here pretty quickly and
didn't really explain it so these are
the methods and we're gonna look at this
in just a few minutes but then also
these are things you can do with this
type of variable so name right now my
name is a string and you can tell that
it's a string because it lives inside
these quotation marks and basically the
way that I like to explain it too big to
beginners is is if it's not a number
it's a string so basically and then you
have your variation of boolean and
binary so boolean czar binary we're
gonna learn about conditions and tests
and things like that and that's the way
a computer can either tell it's either
yes or no true or false and we'll delve
into that so what the way that we're
gonna do things today and for the next
few weeks is we're gonna go forward and
we're gonna go backwards so we're gonna
be exposed to something then we're gonna
move move on then we're gonna come back
and we're gonna dig deeper so we're just
gonna move back and forth and back and
forth so alright so now to prove that
Python and I know what we're talking
about STR so python says ok I know that
name is a string and you want to know
that it is a string so here we go
now what things so we have our X so we
do type X int and type Y we have a float
and then type true we have a blue so now
what we need to look at are the things
that we can do that we can do with these
things
so this right
here like I said is idle shell you might
have even even heard rep ripple so you
got read evaluate print and loop the
next thing is computers can do the same
thing over and over and over again that
that a person a human gets bored with
frustrated and will make a mistake now
when you're over here in this is one
thing that I love showing new people is
Python only knows exactly what you tell
it so I just type name in all caps and
it it kicked back in error so this is a
perfect example of how you can learn and
become a better programmer because
you're going to sit here and you're
gonna look and you're gonna make a
mistake and Python is gonna tell you
exactly where and what mistake you made
so it kicks out a name error and it gave
you the name name is not defined and you
wait a minute yes I know I defined it oh
I come up here and I see that I forgot
that it's all lowercase
now I've thrown out a lot of built-in
functions pretty quickly so and again
I'm assuming that you are completely
brand new to Python and we're it's
summertime we're coming up to school
you're trying to get prepared for fall
classes and especially with everything
going on this is a complete beginner
course starting from scratch you know
nothing we're gonna build on it so one
important fact that you need to know
about me is I've been doing I've been
learning Python for about seven years so
you if you have any concern that you
won't be able to learn Python I started
learning at 36 years old and if I can do
it anybody can do it
so I want to the the purpose of this
also is to keep you guys motivated
and going through and proving that you
can learn to do this if I can learn to
do this anybody can learn to do this all
right here we go
so okay somebody just commented 36 yeah
I was I was 36 when I started and like I
said if I can do this anybody can so
what I like to really teach people is I
start with print and so you can remember
the Association so Python helps you
really a tremendous amount just with the
with the shell in idle so you got print
purple parentheses so now we assigned
the variable we linked it with our equal
sign you guys are if you have no
exposure to programming and especially
Python you're used to the equal sign
showing a balance between an equation in
equilibrium well in Python what it does
is it links the information to it and
again we'll delve into that more but
let's just let's just work on and
understand that it's linked together so
the information and I'll say this and
again we'll expand upon this everything
on the right side is done first and then
that information is linked and
associated with the variable name so
variable name equal sign information so
now so I did that with name and then I
just typed it into the chevrons or the
repple and i hit enter and I got my name
out the information i associated it with
with our equal sign it doesn't really
look pretty so python has functions
already built-in for us so print purple
parentheses very important and let's
also talk about this now computers like
to know when something starts and when
something finishes so I showed you one
mistake I'm going to show you another
so right here I'm gonna hit enter Python
sits here and looks and goes what are
you doing so now I close this out and if
you look really really quickly it Gray's
out so Python says okay I know what
you're talking about you close this now
let's actually look at reassigning and
making a mistake so if I do this and I
leave off a quotation mark I get this
long weird syntax err
ah I forgot to close this out now I'm
gonna show you another way if I can
spell my name and you can get there we
go so now
so let's look up here Sam is all in
green now I started typing Sam and it's
black
well python goes you didn't tell me you
wanted to have a quotation at the
beginning so now also we are going to
expand upon this but I recommend
especially if you're brand new use
double quotation marks so you can you
can use single but we'll we can work
through this but there are levels of
quotation you can use double or single
but right now until you get very
comfortable let's use the double
quotation marks so alright oops
name equals let's get this in memory
alright so now let's go back to what we
can do here and also Dirar
is your friend when you get stuck and
you can't remember what a character what
an object can do so we're gonna start
adding new words everything in Python is
an object and then a lot of these are
have classes so we'll begin to build say
movies switching to Members Only chat
okay
so now we identified that this is a
string STR so now we can run help on STR
a string aha
now this is another very powerful part
of python the amount of documentation
that we have now so what help does is it
goes through and it has the actual
description and a small little
definition if if it's unable to be
really understood so these are methods
and we'll delve into what those are and
the difference between a method and a
function is they act the same you
utilize them differently so right now
let's run let's look at so I did der on
name and let's look at what's one that I
like upper so now now so I can call name
and upper is sitting right there so I
call upper boom return a copy and we are
gonna talk a lot about return and other
terminologies but return a copy of a
string converted to upper case so if I
call name dot upper now super important
here parentheses starting finishing
beginning and ending so we add our
quotations we had one at the beginning
one at the end when we used help and dur
and print we added open parenthesis and
we had a closed parenthesis now look
right here upper open and closed so I
just go boom and it will return that
just means create Python
is going to create something and go
forward so create a copy so now if I
still call name I still have my original
variable and this just spit out so if I
wanted to create create a new variable
and it was all uppercase I would take my
information put it on the left side
associated link it with my equal sign
and give it a variable alright so now I
have name and I have upper and look at
that guess what
kicked out cuz i cant spell sometimes so
I put one too many
one too many peas in there so then it
kicked out Sam all uppercase so we'll
delve into if not all of these because
these are very powerful and very handy
and usable and then we go from there so
all right now now what we need to do is
we need to look at all right
so right now like I was saying this is
the shell this is like live television
when you especially when I show young
people this at schools and they try to
come back up here and fix something you
can't this is this is the repple this is
the shell this is live this is like live
television
but for repeatability pythons one of
pythons way to be able to do things over
and over and over again is you come up
to file click new file and then you have
something called a script but I already
have one set up and sized so so I have
it over here and I want you to draw your
attention to this dot py so when you're
opening yours you're gonna do either
ctrl shift s or
down here to save as and then you give
it your file that whatever name I
recommend the date or the beginning of
beginning Python one thing that is super
important and I've answered a lot of
questions on message boards and
especially later when you get more
advanced don't ever name your file the
name of the file of the library you're
working that's why that's why I
recommend dates or the beginning subject
matter that you're working on because
you're gonna have a circular import
error so that's that's a side note of
something very futuristic so that's why
I like that's why I like dates that's
why I recommend starting with dates so
now so we got name and s a.m. s a.m. now
print name so what is awesome about this
and so you see this little run up here
and you got run module f5 so as long as
your cursor is in this script over here
it will run it will kick this out you'll
get this and it's gonna say hey and also
right here asterisk see this asterisk
right up here in this corner beside the
filename that means you've changed that
file and it has something that hasn't
been saved to it so that's why you get
this prompt right here you hit f5 you
get this prompt because something has
changed so then you click OK it runs now
this is important and I remember when I
was learning I it was driving me nuts
what when you see restart it just
emptied out everything that was in
memory so uppers gone everything
everything that you had before so this
does a complete memory dump right here
and then the only thing in memory is
everything in your script so script file
your py however you want to think about
this but all of this is to save your
mental well-being so you don't have to
retype something over and over and over
and over again so alright oops
I just lost all the chat well we'll work
on that later all right if you're just
joining us today I'm Sam with Python
basics and this is going to be a
complete beginner series in Python and
this actually came about by on my
channel
I think there's seven hundred and forty
videos and I wanted to I partnered with
Bo and we were talking about kind of
starting over so this is basically a
recap of and for the next few weeks
we're gonna we're gonna get through the
first hundred and really start delving
into all of the other videos but that's
where all this is so if by chance you're
like me and you want to get ahead and
know what we're gonna talk about before
we talk about it you can go the links
down below to all those but this chain
this these streams are designed for
brand new people and especially I
started thinking about it about it being
summertime right before school is going
to be starting that there's going to be
plenty of people that are going to be
wanting to really get ahead with their
programming skills and especially the
popularity of Python but I have a great
passion for Python I've been learning it
for seven years been teaching it for
about five so I know I can get excited
pretty easy and fly through some of this
material so bear with me hold on and
we'll get through all this together so
let's talk about some more repeatability
and also actually before we get into
that we need to look at this so we
looked at derp also you run derp with
zero arguments I know that's a word you
may not have heard before but you leave
out the parentheses
excuse me you leave the parentheses
empty you get everything that's in
memory right now and we'll talk about
all this stuff later but there we are
with our name our name variable so now
the same thing with help if you put help
here and you pass it zero arguments you
get the you get the prompt help so we
looked at we looked at strings now let's
look at some key words as again like
I've like I've been saying Python is so
powerful because of its vast width and
depth of its community so let's look at
some more repeatability so we already
just talked about a file for
repeatability then now we need to look
at something that is very powerful is
something a way that you can do over and
over and over and over again and one of
these ways is with a loop I made a
comment made a brief comment about
ripple read evaluate print and loop well
there are two types of loop and with
Python and we're gonna focus on the for
loop right now and the reason why I
wanted to show you these keywords let's
get out of there is one of the other
powerful things about Python is it gives
you some color hints and because being
dyslexic dyslexic and being not being
able to spell so when I'm writing a word
and it doesn't go the color that I
expect that helps me when I have to when
I'm trying to find out why my program is
not running very well and I will tell
you another one that just is the bane of
my existence lambda I have to usually
try that three or four times so now
we're gonna learn about a second
built-in or excuse me our R so we did
help we did type we did derp we did
print now we're gonna so that's five so
now we're gonna look learn about rain
so what range does is this is a very
interesting function so it has some
characteristics to it in the programming
you need to be able to do something a
certain amount of times so one of those
tools is range so in a few look right
here you got stop so if I give it one
argument I get stop but if I give it
more than one the rules changed so let's
just go through it so I'm gonna use a
new keyword for then I'm gonna give it a
variable it's a temporary intermittent
variable another keyword in and then
we're gonna pass it and we want this to
do this three times so I know I know I
just did a lot right here so this is
actually called the header and
everything inside this is called the
body and this this also we're gonna see
this in our own built-in functions and
we're gonna do that very very soon so
keyword for temporary variable in this
so this has to be an iterable alright
and we're gonna go into more definitions
more terms like I said we're gonna we're
gonna go forward and backwards are gonna
move back and forth so this is an
iterable and now one thing that a lot of
new people do is they forget that colon
at the end and you can learn right here
quickly that I forgot something I want
to draw everybody's eyes and attention
to this down here in this corner so I'm
on column zero Python automatically
indents for so now I'm here on column
four so that's how I know and it goes
when you have multiple levels you go in
for every single time so we're gonna
print we're gonna do this slow
everything I talk fast but I go slow if
that makes sense all right so I want
something to happen
three times and right now all we're
gonna do is print out name and name is
associated to Sam its we have Sam
assigned to name and I want this printed
out three times and this is my temporary
variable so I works or even a blank
underscore all right so yes it is going
to be a full series and we'll build up
to a code editor but the reason what
this is the way that we're doing these
streams is this is for absolute complete
beginners absolute complete beginners we
don't want anybody I don't want anybody
feeling overwhelmed that they can't
learn this so I ran across some videos
and basically the way that all of this
is designed is what how what
organization what structure what I would
have wanted if if if I was starting to
learn over again so this is not
important this is only if you're going
to do something with this over and guess
what we're gonna do that in just a
minute so this is going to print out so
you got your header and your body
basically what do you want to do and
what are you doing so what do you want
to do
how do you want to do it and what do you
want to do so let's run this so now I
get my f5 and I have a let's comment way
to learn about we need to talk about
commenting ah for the younger people in
the crowd you might know the pound sign
is a hash tag well that's a comment so
whenever you see red colors in Python
are very important so red means it's
been commented out so that just threw
off everything so now you're like what
why did it quite Sam come out for so
let's rerun this alright so Sam came out
three times so here we go so I commented
this out and I quickly did that with all
three you can also come up here comment
out region
uncommon out region so alt three and out
for I can highlight and do this so
alright so now like I said throughout a
little bit of a term this is called an
iterable and we're gonna throw it into a
container in a minute but right now
let's change this to I actually let's
leave this and so you guys can see all
of it especially if you guys are joining
us now let's see yes okay alright and
let's see so we're gonna copy this and
we're gonna change this to AI and change
this to AI and guess what we're gonna
comment all this out so we highlight the
region and then we press our alt three
comments it out and let's see make sure
okay you guys can see that good now I'm
going to press my f5 and we're gonna see
what happens now something different
that you're may not be expecting so
alright 0 1 2 I that's still three
numbers right so let's look at range one
more time and still no I didn't spell it
right cuz it didn't go purple all right
if I give you have this handy tool and
I'm not even using it so I'm gonna put
range in our help oh here we go
so range stop range object range start
stop let's read this return an object
that produces a sequence of integers
start it's inclusive means it is
included stop is exclusive means it goes
right up into but does not include well
what we just find out here 3 I want I
want three numbers a Python is a zero
index language
starts at zero think about a number line
and the reason why I say this is because
we're gonna address this in a minute
with negative indexing and especially
when we get into slicing slicing strings
so it starts starts dead in the middle
at zero and it goes positive
I think I'm pointing for you it might be
that way it goes positive and then of
course negative so you don't want to
have a gap in the number line so that's
why gordo decided to start at zero zero
indexing and then go positive so we got
zero one two still has three numbers
just it starts start step stop just like
this so when you give it two numbers the
first one is the first argument is start
second one is stop and then you have
step so now if I change this so the
start sequence is inclusive stop is
exclusive so I have one two three four
five the five is not included its
exclusive it's excluded so how many
numbers will come out one two three four
now now let's get now now let's learn
about a container so we got four
different types of variables we got
strings you got in so we got floats
we got bullying's now we need to figure
out a way so basically you're saying so
I have to sign all these variables well
not necessarily now there's also we're
gonna learn about a list and a list is
one of the basic containers dope list
and it's literally like that and guess
there we go
so haha it's an iterable built-in
mutable so we're gonna talk about that
later
that mutable just means you can change
it and then let's look at der on list
and here we are we're not gonna worry
about these double underscores and I
don't think you'll ever hear me say
dunder
I don't think double underscore methods
and then here the methods that we would
utilize so let's go and we're gonna do
something very cool so we need to list
of five so we have our range five now
what is so super cool with Python it's
like I said Python doesn't care as long
as it's legal and you do everything on
the right side of the equal sign then
it's then link it then give it a
variable this is completely legal so I
take my range and Python knows okay so
it's zero one two three four because
that's five numbers I started zero okay
I know what you want alright then now
you want this around the list function
so you want to turn that into a list
okay I can do that
so now and I kind of alluded to that so
here are brackets so this is our first
basic container holder of stuff and will
become more elaborate holder of objects
in Python and these are intz so now when
I run type on my L underscore 5 and it
helps if I close this out it gets back
the class of list now let's talk about
some rules for variables we have not
done that yet there are there Python has
Python is a language Python has rules so
basically when you start programming and
you start building have a project and
then you build it to functionality in
the project and you have functions
inside the functionality and then you're
going and you're going and you're Sean
and you're getting smaller and smaller
and smaller so you have to take a
project and get it down to remembering
information and doing something over and
over and over again
maybe analyzing it may be a little bit
more but that's how simple you have to
get this so what I'm teaching people I
say that you have to get it down to the
bare bones of can you explain this to a
five-year-old if you can explain this to
a five-year-old you can write this as a
program or you can have a function and
that's that's how you have to go so how
much do you have to indent the code all
right the code will indent itself if now
if you're in sublime you may have to now
you want to get very careful with
spacing and tabs that's why if you're
new I want you to be I want you to start
here so you can begin to really
understand you can get I remember I
equate this to the lesson that I learned
when I was playing tennis I've had a
tennis pro and I told him that he was
better than me because of his racket so
we changed rackets and he beat me with
my own racket so we're learning the
basics we're learning Python don't get
hung up on the editors let's learn the
skills first you learn the skills then
then you can use the editors this is
fine for what we're doing for several
weeks all right so we have some rules
for Python has a couple rules for
variables cannot contain a special
character cannot start with a number
cannot start with a number
all right cannot start with a number and
cannot be a keyword and so that's why I
showed you these so these are already
used in Python same thing also they
can't be a function name all right so we
can all right so now we're 37 minutes
and we're going pretty good we're going
strong so if you're just joining us I'm
Sam with Python basics and we're gonna
be doing an entire series for complete
complete absolute beginners and the what
I was kind of thinking and Bobo and I
chatted and I would appreciate Bo for
giving me this opportunity to be here
with you guys but I have a great passion
for Python I learned it later later in
life starting at 36 so if I can do it
anybody can
so I've been learning for seven years
and I've been teaching for five so I've
gotten down some pretty pretty good
material and I've had a YouTube channel
for almost three and a half now it's
only three three years and four months
so tons of videos over there and Bobo
and I were talking that we just kind of
wanted to start over from those and
compress these and put these into some
live streams so thanks for joining us
today and we're gonna be doing this
every Tuesday for the foreseeable future
so all right how much let's continue
with on with where we are so we just
looked at that we called repeatability
we got our scripts so here we go so now
all right so now so we ran we ran this
let's pull this back up let's touch on
this again so we have our range
we have when we give to two digits and I
apologize for copying it was not that
big of a deal I should not have copied
that now let's look at this print I
let's comment this out now what did we
see about start/stop step and step is
will will be omitted but I thought it
used to say interval does not say
interval anymore
alright thinking about your times table
steps let's change this to two so what
should come out right here any any
thoughts I don't have a chat anymore any
thoughts of what should come out so we
know it's gonna start it - and it's
going to go by twos right here two four
six eight
wait a second I want to tend to come out
so oh that's right
ten is the stop is two four six eight
exactly right
[Music]
Jan no ten why not ten very good
question why not ten his stop is
exclusive so if I wanted to get ten to
come out I need to go past ten stop is
include is exclusive right up in to but
not including the stop position so I
went past because we're going by twos
but technically really I just need to go
to 11 I just need to get past 10 to go
to have 10 be included because the stop
is exclusive right up into so great
question so now now let's
change this a little bit because I want
I want to I want to wrap so now I want
to look at iterables as another because
right here this is a so this is this
returns an object of sequence so it's as
iterable but let's let's see what we did
here so we took so we got our L you
don't want to do see if I do this list
it's not gonna work so that's why we did
our l5 and we wrapped list around range
v close this out let's go over this real
close so I do five I gray out I get
around this and I grant out one more
time and I get all my contents
so now let's comment this out we're
going to type some more for I mean and
so let's look at this number num in L
underscore five I get my because it is
that that is the same rule it a so we so
the rules for a variable R can't contain
a special character can't start with a
number and it can't be a keyword or a
function so there we go those are three
rules now print num so here's my
temporary intermediary variable and
right here now
now let's look at one more very
important
feather function my goodness sorry guys
I cannot type today Len short for length
return the number of items in a
container so now Len on L underscore
five close this out five so there we go
so now when I run this what will happen
anybody
Jan you got any you got any guesses so
if I run if I press f5 what will what
will happen I don't know how much of a
delay there is on my end and chat so I'm
gonna run this I don't know if you're
sitting there watching me going why
hasn't he pressed it yet so same rules
apply here now let's do let's do
something cool because now I changed it
to just one integer so it reverts back
to starting at zero yes you're good
you're good
so when you pass in one integer to range
help on range you pass in one integer
it's only the stop point so zero through
right up into not including the stop
point so that's why this was for so now
so now what happens
it's alright this is also where it gets
really cool so now that I'm inside the
body right here
I can I can list however many
instructions I want okay
alright guys I was probably big loud and
duddy
okay so print all right and print num x
actually let's do this over here first
we need to talk about this so we have
not talked about operators yet so python
was built upon the basics and again
that's why this thing is so so very
powerful so it just jumps out as a
calculator so you got your standard
multiplication subtraction excuse me
addition subtraction multiplication
division exponents and there are a
couple others that need needed to be
added so we got our party to that so 1
minus 1 then you have 5 times 2 6
divided by 3 now here's how you handle
exponents so to two asterisks is
exponent and then so where it gets very
important and when you're dealing with
floats and integers and guess what we'll
get to that there is a way so if I go
and divide so as you can see right here
this kicks back a float well when you're
doing specific things and you're
expecting one type of integer excuse me
one type of object and you get a
different type of object that can be a
problem so guess what Python has a way
to handle that so this is floor division
it removes it removes everything that
you don't need now one of the very cool
operators that took me a long time to
figure out was the modulo this is what
is so cool it's the remainder so right
here let's go five divided by three I
get one point six six
so five modulo 3 I get two
okay so three goes in two times no three
goes in one time or it almost goes in -
no let's do long division so three goes
in - five one whole time and the
remainder is 2 or two-thirds so we're
gonna have a very interesting exercise
in a very nice problem especially when
you're trying to solve mathematics and
you're looking for a ways to handle
rounding this modulo is a very important
character so all right a little bit of
side note so we're gonna do print we're
just gonna give an empty line and we're
gonna do print num times 2 so I want I
want the number Venice then a blank then
a and actually we're gonna add another 1
print so we're gonna do the number then
a blank line then the number times 2
then a blank line so let's run this so I
will get okay 0 0 Z 1 2 2 4 now let's
change the skill you know what I don't
like that I don't like that one there I
want to do number number x 2 then a
blank line and then go to the top so
this is what's very powerful about loops
and also then you have to plan and think
about loop control flow of the program
how are you going to be doing this and I
think we're gonna get to it today we're
gonna do a number triangle I love
teaching this because this is a perfect
example of how do you control which and
control the flow of the program and you
have to think about it you have to go
through the order of events and how can
I do this in a form that can do this
every single time that is that is the
challenge of a loop is that what order
of events can I do this every single
time with maybe a variation at the
beginning or a variation at the end to
kick outside of it
so now let's run this again alright so I
get 0/0 blank line one two blank line
two for blank line three six and four
eight
so the order of events are one time
through I do all of this then it kicks
back up here so all right we're gonna
expand upon this sorry I can get sucked
in and talk about loops for hours so all
right let's see what is next all right
so we need to now look at some slicing
just slicing has the same rules as let's
bring in same UEL it's alright
so now you have slicing and indexing so
we've seen parentheses and we've seen a
bracket with a list so when I give
Python brackets and one digit beside a
string variable I will get a singular
character this is the zero index alright
so this is one this is two three four
and so on but the same rules apply if I
now with our range function I gave I
used commas with slicing I use
quotations so we're gonna we're gonna
look at this
zero for so what in the world just
happened so let's look at this I start
at zero I go through up to but not
including hey let's come over here so
let's look at another quick comment way
to do this so if I give three quotation
marks everything inside this is not
looked at by the computer so I got zero
one two three four five
let's pace this out some that was very
good
that looks jumbled okay there we go
shrink this a little bit so we can see
both them side-by-side all right so I
got zero I got 1 2 3 not including I did
not include 4 now we need to look at
this so when I leave now with our range
function you could not leave one of them
blank but with the string you can omit
zero and pass in the colon so Python
goes okay you know what you're talking
about you know you want to use the stop
location and we kind of understand each
other that you know what you're doing
and you want to start at zero and then
you want to stop at five so I close this
out so I go to 5 to 5 not including 5
and that's why I stopped at eat now so
let's see so now I go name
boom if I leave the other one blank
I'm telling Python hey I want all of it
I want I'm with the whole thing now
there's a couple ways that you could do
this in Reverse and this is this is just
one of the things that I just love about
pythons all right
same rules start stop step start stop
step now so if I go by twos start stop
step I want start at the beginning go
all the way to the end and I want you to
go by twos so start at zero start at
zero skip every other so boom boom so
that's why I only get s/m II start and
come over here now all right now let's
look at how to go backwards negative so
I'm going negative in Reverse one time
so this is a way that you can take this
string and reverse it so this is a very
cool test if you've ever heard of
palindrome so pallette palindrome so
this is a very good test to how could
you take in exactly is is exactly it is
the same rules that's why I like to tie
these together range you can look at the
documentation for help on range and then
we slide over to slicing with strings
the exact same rules so that's why I
like to include this what you'll notice
about me and the way that we're going to
do things is we're gonna have
Association and then we're gonna have
reinforced learning so we're gonna learn
a couple of things together that acts
similar and then it's gonna revert back
to something and it's gonna support it
so we're gonna we're getting our good
base down we're quit getting waiting
that we're building a good foundation
and then we're gonna build upon it we're
not gonna rush through anything if
anything we're gonna go over a couple
things several times
and hopefully while we're here together
you're gonna get something that you've
never seen before because that's what I
tried to do I wanted to let her in the
stream can't do that what if we only
want to omit one letter in the string
you want to just omit one oh okay so you
just want to jump over one letter
alright so there is because we were
actually going to get to something like
that so now one of the other issues with
strings are let's look at help STR
string we need to do we need to look at
this where does it say it watch it not
say it in here for me
immutable you cannot change a string but
you can use parts you can use the whole
string parts of strings and here's the
little bit that can get confusing at
first until you really start thinking
about it you can add to a string but
you're actually then creating a new
object really but alright so let's say
we wanted to so we got we got Sam right
name
actually that's shorten it to just Sam
so now mm-hmm
we're gonna do this in a minute so this
is very great question we're gonna take
a bank of well let's build upon this so
if I just wanted am to come out how how
could I do this so we can look at how to
slice up and chop this up in the middle
so how would I get so if I know 0 starts
s how could I get a to start where would
I need to where would I need to go what
would I need to type right here
so I say start at 1 and index 1 go all
the way to the end include everything I
get am so now
all right this is called concatenation
just a fancy word to say adding strings
together all right
so P should do it oh okay
Jan I think I know what you're saying
but hang on a second so if I want so if
you did that that's going every other
letter and I don't know if that was
named for Sam or Samuel but then that so
if I wanted to if I just wanted am to
come out it's one starting it starting
at this index one second letter always
be off by one especially when we start
doing our number triangle here in a
little bit you're always going to be a
you usually only off by one either side
plus or minus one so we got oops I typed
that wrong let's come up here
all right so what did i do so name
slicing starting it won't index one then
going through so I got am right here and
I added I concatenated P with am and
that's how I got Pam and then you got so
then if I made a bank right here this is
I love this exercise so bear with me so
if I make a string and I do
P t.j what's the other one I do ya for
and I still have name yep so this is
going to call name up here just to
remind you for letter in letters so this
is a group this is a string this is an
iterable so i can place this here this
is an iterable so then I get my colon
then print letter plus name just like we
did over there close this out alright
this is this is my building block this
is just the same rule I'm just using
variables alright let's put this into
memories we'll go slow we'll go slow so
letters what is this
so if I go for letter in letters print
letter I'm going to get each one of
these I'm iterating through an iterable
one at a time
ptj be alright
so that was my building blocks I'm
iterating through my iterable one letter
at a time so here's my temporary
variable and I remember that this is am
and I'm adding em to the end of each
letter which comes out ptj B so then now
I hit my f5 and now I get pam Tam cam
BAM alright does that make sense
any questions about that
alright cool let's keep going our one is
down so alright if you're new here
thanks for joining us I'm Sam and with
Python basics and we're gonna be doing a
live stream once a week for two hours
and basically this is a compressed
course of all the videos off of my
youtube channel seven hundred plus
videos and we Bo and I been talkin and I
had been experimenting with live streams
and free code camp has given me this
wonderful opportunity so I just want to
make sure I tell them thank you thank
you to them and thank you to Bo for this
wonderful chance to share this because I
just love Python absolutely so much I
think it is a doorway to so many things
for anybody who wants to learn anybody
who wants to give any effort to
programming because if I can learn how
to do this I promise you I can teach
anybody because I was 36 I'm Dyslexic
ADHD any issue you can think of I got it
I learned it I love teaching this it is
a powerful tool it changes the way you
think it changes your outlook it I want
you guys to stay motivated
alright I want to UM I'm here to keep
you guys going so
let's keep going let's keep going so now
so we've done a little bit of slicing
we've done a little bit of concatenation
so now now we need to really look at
what did I want to look at next
so we sliced the strings ooh
we haven't even built a function yet so
let's go ahead and do that so all right
we have been using all of pythons built
in everything so now I like to I like to
build on from our from our loops into
our function they do the exact same
thing so that it's designed the same you
have your header and then you have your
body and that's it and the same rules
apply so let's just go ahead and do this
that's coming out all this so we don't
have any stragglers stuff and also very
important side note don't ever delete
anything I remember I was going I was
like oh I'll remember this I you got
tons of hard drive space there's stuff
in the cloud
don't ever delete anything you've ever
written when it's kind of cool to go
back and look and see what you've done
in the past but don't delete it just
commented it out save it and also one
important thing to really learn is make
sure when you're writing programs you
put comments in them because what I have
a challenge for you is if you've been
programming awhile go back and look at
one of your programs you wrote a year
ago or even six months ago see if you
didn't put any comments in there see if
you can remember what in the world you
were trying to do so I now we're gonna
build our first
function let's get this up here so it's
all towards the top so all right now
we're gonna learn about another keyword
and we know it's a keyword because it is
orange so let's let's come and remind
ourselves help keywords keywords and I'm
there I'm at our interactive help prompt
and you get to there by typing in help
with zero arguments all right and as you
can see now we have Def and passing Def
and oh wow okay so we use this for
defining a function okay there we go so
let's jump into it so yeah if you can't
ever remember exactly what something
does especially I remember I was going
nuts oh I'm like how am I gonna what do
i what is that what does that keyword do
what does that keep oh wait a minute
yeah I have my interactive help and I
can ask about that keyword so all right
we're gonna just gonna type hello I
think it's good if you get a zero all
right so the way that I like to explain
this is you need five things on your
header your DEF keyword the name of your
functions your parentheses your colon
because if you leave your colon out you
go back to under death on the edge
column zero you have a problem so you
make sure you put your colon in there
and Python will take care of it in the
script and indent for for you now stuff
in the middle the argument inside the
function is optional right now we're not
gonna take in anything we're just gonna
print out hello and it helps if you pass
it a string all right my goodness guys
I'm very sorry for the typing today so
let's look at the same same setup
sorry same setup so if when I'm here I
go down Python says hey do you have any
more instructions I'm sitting here I'm
waiting on at your beck and call and
you're like no actually I'm done so now
that just now little variation just like
when we created so I put this into
memory looks like nothing happens so
same thing just like when we did our
variable we put it into memory and it
looks like nothing happened but then we
had to call it right so we did this when
to the next line you're like nothing
happened well actually a lot happen same
thing over here
so in our file in our script we created
then we called it we put it into memory
but where did we call it we haven't
actually called the function so we just
go hello and it's a function and as you
can see python helps it says hey doesn't
take any arguments just pass parenthesis
and you're like okay cool
now if you're like me you're gonna want
to see this thing run so you're gonna so
I'm here inside my function right and
I'm coming here I'm coming here I'm
coming here well I need I get outside
the function I'm not inside so like I
said we're gonna build it we're gonna
add we're gonna sprinkle we're gonna add
we're gonna go back we're gonna go
backwards and we're gonna add we're
gonna add all right Python tracks white
spaces this white space right here
Python goes haha okay you know what
you're talking about you just made up
function and everything I'm gonna do
everything inside this function and when
I get outside the function then I'm
gonna go through so just like our for
loop Python comes down here and it loops
through everything here once it gets to
the bottom exterminates at the bottom
goes back up to the top same thing with
the function it's gonna read all this
and then kick outside here so if I want
to then inside this file inside this
script call the function after I put it
into memory I come down below it
and then just call said function just
like I did here so I just put it over
here now it can't be inside the function
that's another type of issue we'll deal
with that later but we'll jump into that
very very soon all right so here we go
I get hello now now let's do a little
bit more so now I'm gonna pass in Sam
[Music]
name then concatenate name so then I
give it there we go alright so now I'm
taking it information here's my here's
my argument my first my first exposure
to an argument I'm then going to print
hello along with this argument this
variable and then down here when I'm
calling the function I'm passing in this
so the way that I want you to look at
this is this is the variable from here
right same concept same concept where we
have the information the variable and
then we're utilizing that variable here
so now we're passing this in this goes
here so visualize this as Sam and Sam
now there is a problem here and we're
gonna see it and then we're gonna fix it
and I love teaching young people and
they say I did it wrong well it didn't
do it right it didn't put a space in
there okay well show us where we put the
space we didn't put a space anywhere so
of course the computer it's not gonna
guess it's not gonna hope it's not gonna
go oh I know you meant to put a space in
there it's not gonna do that
so we're gonna come here we're gonna run
boom hello Sam alright now huh now why
don't we write now we have this program
and it's not even close to an end user I
gotta get into the program to put my
name in there well guess what pythons
got something for you help
input let's pull this over these get
bigger and bigger so alright let's go
back to chat who has seen the input
function before anybody okay so read a
string from standard input trailing
trailing newline is stripped the prompt
string if given senior output with a
trailing newline before reading in it's
alright what this is basically saying
you have okay cool so basically now
we're gonna get rid of this we're gonna
get and we're gonna do name input enter
name so now this can you can get user
input from the command line but that's
gonna be at least a video or two away
because that's dealing with assists RV
and I don't want to we're not we're not
to that point where we're still dealing
with beginner beginning or stuff but yes
you were coming completely completely
accurate there as a way to grab all
input from the command line and that is
some very powerful stuff with Python and
I I love it I love it I don't I don't
want to get sucked into that crack quite
yet I want to I want to deal with all
the basics first but we are we are going
to get to that and we're actually going
to do some pretty cool stuff with that
so alright so now we have so I got to
get rid of this because this is not we
don't take in any information with our
with our function so I have this
function I then am creating a variable
utilizing the input utilizing the input
function I'm passing any in some prompt
in then I'm taking that information and
going forward alright so now let's go
through this enter name
go whoo I don't like that it's right
there on that colon so we're gonna fix
that later and we do that just by this
boom so now I have my space right here
let's run this again so now my prompt is
sitting right here it's now I go Sam
oh very cool okay so now now I have this
now now I now we're gonna look at this
and let's close comment that out now
we're going to look at how to def rent
so I want blank print into blank so then
I call blank and what happens get a
blank line all right
death blank
three so now I want three blank lines so
now I'm gonna call blank three times so
the reason why I'm showing you this is I
know I could use print but the the point
of this exercise is to show you that you
can begin to little eyes so now I got
three lines so now now I'm gonna go deaf
blink nine so instilled sorry blank
three and I'm gonna cheat a little don't
tell nobody do not recommend this okay
so now I call blank underscore nine open
closed run this and now I get nine so
the point of this exercise is to begin
to show you that where this becomes very
powerful is so I don't have to go in
here and type I don't have to type print
three times three times so or nine so
this is the building block of how you
would go in create a function be able to
utilize that function at a later time
and then even expand upon it so that was
one of the first things cuz when when
computer programs refers to being built
you had to go in and do the exact same
command over and over and over again I I
can only imagine what that what that
could be and had to be like and then
then they designed efficiencies hey
there's got to be a way for us to do
this over and over again and the first
one was the go-to line and then and then
it was like okay do we really need to
then go back up there so we have this
thing circulating so then they came up
with a way to have a function
and then it has developed and evolved
and then files and then boom boom boom
because I mean if if you're here
anywhere near my age the computers were
actually the information was actually
saved on magnet tapes it would search
the tape and coil and spin and run that
was the original hard drive it was it
was nuts all right I digress
but all right it's a little ads we got
another bunch of time that went by if
you're just joining us today thanks for
being here can you can I call the
function with the same function like
blank function inside the blank function
yeah but I don't want to get into that
right now that's recursion and that you
can do that for certain purposes if you
mean to especially we're gonna have an
exercise a recursive function but what
am i what am i trying to think oh we're
we swap Fibonacci so the Fibonacci
sequence can you call the function from
within a print function he when given an
example Jana what he I mean you can but
all it would do is print out the
function can you get an example what
you're wanting to do because here if I
call because you're gonna get something
like this that's what it would look like
so okay yes oh well I'm glad to hear
that I'm very I'm very glad you you
joined cuz look it like like you've like
if you're just joining us right now I've
been given this wonderful opportunity to
livestream with you guys and Python has
just changed everything about me and I
know that sounds a little cheesy but I
mean it has it's given me a bunch of new
skills the way that I see everything the
way that I problem-solve I've been able
to teach Python and my kids school been
able to expose a great deal of people
I've had a YouTube channel for over
three years
it is just a wonderful tool that is out
there so yes I'm going to be doing we're
gonna be doing this for a very very long
time and I don't see it slowing down at
all if anything I see it going faster so
alright
but yes you you do have a function call
other functions and especially a
Fibonacci sequence well well I really
appreciate that thank you very much
all right so we have a function calling
other functions and all this baby
basically is and then we're gonna get it
we can get into nested functions later
for example if you want to user gender
the gender the character in the program
standardizes their input these are
integers the character is male and the
sentence would say the character is a
male okay I'll look at that later I
think I get that let's see if I can copy
that all right
I'm copying that question right now
and I'll look at it I don't want to slow
all of us down but Jan that's a good
question I'll look at I think I know
what you're saying but I don't want to
not answer I got I got some other stuff
I want to go through but I will examine
that and if you go to my my channel
and then there's an email address that
you can email me and we will we can we
can chat about that or you can send me a
paste bin if you have a script that
you're kind of working on and I can I
can help you with that all right
so cool oh I think we're to the point
where we need to we're gonna do the oh
yeah okay we need to look at how to
start looking at making decisions so we
need to because we're talking about
modulo so we need to now bring in we're
gonna make a list numbers and it's gonna
be
we're gonna go one five two four six ten
and I don't think I have three so print
number and numbers print number so what
I want to do is I want to we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna build we're
gonna start small okay so we got our we
we got where we can go through our our
list so now we need to find out and we
want to print out if if each number is
odd or even and I made one little
concept one little passing comment about
a tool so is anybody have any guesses
how in the world we could begin to use
the tools that we have to find out if a
number is odd or even or I guess how
would you explain to a five-year-old
what an odd number is and what an even
number is any comments Jan you've been
doing awesome and they're super
interactive any any quick comments how
you describe to a five-year-old what a
what an odd or even number is alright
best description for the tools that we
have is if a number is divisible by 2
with a remainder of 0 all right so now
if a number can be divided by itself
it's even okay all numbers where I'm at
hang on if a number it can be divided by
itself it's even by two yes absolutely
with a little a little bit of but with a
little bit of caveat with a remainder of
zero so we have to have that little we
have to have that they're all evenly
divided evenly divided that that's where
the sticky the stickiness of this gets
so now we've learned about how to use an
equal sign to link information
information to a variable now now we
need to learn how to find equivalence
the boom
okay very very good if there is a
remainder of zero awesome modulo we're
gonna it's going to be like this if you
guys are looking at the comments that is
exactly it so this is then how you do a
condition so another keyword keywords
and if alphabetic order for me ready to
go artists if
all right conditional statement
conditional execution and the way that
we do this is one equal to one is one
the way that I recommend and say put in
is in front of it to help put you until
you get very comfortable this is one
equal to one two equal signs is the
equilibrium one equal sign is
Association linking assigning
association linking assigning two equal
signs equivalency test true is one equal
to zero false so now so now now we have
inside our for loop now we're gonna have
some more indention if number on here do
we have a number of still in here
numbers all right so if number modulo
two so i divided by two equals zero
nether colon more indention and i want
you to print out number we're not gonna
do anything else right now so basically
all that should happen right now is we
should only print out because this is
the only instructions we have so we have
we have our loop we have our header loop
now we have our header condition now we
have our specific here's our condition
now actually i want to lets hardwire
this
all right so we're gonna cheat I want I
want to really focus on this this line
will only happen these instructions were
only happen if this line is true all
right so it just printed out everything
I made I just said make everything true
so right here I have one equals one true
one equals zero absolutely not it's
false okay so I hardwired this I made
this true so every single number printed
out so now we're gonna pass in if number
modulo 2 equals zero so now this has to
be true for this to happen all right
so I should only get even numbers to
print out right because this will only
it will only happen it will kick down
here past here and then it exhausted the
instructions and we'll go back up so now
let's run this so I only print it out
even numbers so now how about we saying
let's change this up a little bit
is even all right and I told you to do
this
Here I am giving a fancy bad bad all
right
two is even four is even six is even so
we have the same thing so now bingo else
odd so now we have to the way that
Python works as it goes hey I got you an
if so you don't have to do another if
because we're gonna talk more about that
I don't know if we'll get to that today
think we will we only get we only got in
30 minutes I don't know if we'll get to
that today but you have to have a way to
grab the opposite because
that's that's hardwired this it's
hardwired this right now is false false
and I'm gonna run this nothing happens
because all these are false said nothing
happens it comes up here gets exhausted
so I back this up then now the way that
I did that I know I just typed a lot so
if you're new here see
yeah you're right is that better
I should be probably be more consistent
so now the way that we can do this as I
print number so if this becomes false if
this if this is not true excuse me if
this is not true don't do this
content continue on all right boom so
now I get okay now here we go
one is odd five is odd two is even for
is even six is even ten and so on and
soon I don't know if it's next we need
to then figure out a way and there's
another term actually yeah let's go
ahead and I think I do have that next
all right so now now the next one and we
need to figure this out
is is is a number so
this simple example works because there
are two conditions right we have we have
a positive we have a positive and we
have a positive and excuse me we have an
even in an odd so there's only two
there's only two scenarios what happens
if we have a even or odd number what
would we do I need to add one little one
little caveat here here we go
all right so kind of just gave gave it
away right there so I got I got a set of
numbers let's go through these numbers
for a number and numbers print remember
all right do I have even or odd how am I
gonna excuse me positive or negative I
need to change excuse me I forgot to
change that that and that
so how many conditions will we have if
we have if we have because right there
are even or odd there's only two but if
we do positive or negative it's kind of
a trick question because there's
actually three conditions so we need to
learn about we can we can do this one of
two ways so we're gonna we're going to
do it two ways so I'm gonna do a nested
all right so we print out who did I not
save this is not safe there we go okay
so we got we got some we got some
negative numbers we got negative 5
negative 4 negative 10 0 so let's that's
our that's our little bit of our our
hint right now yep we got three
conditions so how in the world are we
gonna handle those three conditions we
could we could devise this a couple of
different ways so let's let's just go
ahead and get started if no equals zero
print zero Wow
zero now we need to look at this else if
statement alright or another one
shoot help keywords and it's very very
handy very very cool Elif so the reason
why this was created was if you have a
bunch of if conditions this took me a
long time to figure out yeah that was
new to programming and I was old so if
it worked I I went on about my day but
then I started realizing that these that
I was these longer programs and
especially checking these longer lists
and these longer containers this was
taking forever because it was running
through and checking every single if so
the Elif you you utilize Elif so it will
only check the first if and then
exterminate and go out for 0 for even
for even and odd ooh that's actually
kind of cool
so that zero and even and odd alright so
right now I may have been misspeak I was
trying to read some comments so no all
we're gonna do right now is if it's
positive or negative and there's a
there's a trick there's a sneaky
condition in there as if it's zero so if
it's zero do that l if l if number
greater than zero print what positive -
Wow
and then what's the last they all end or
get er la else then negative all right
so let's I agree I agree
I I love this actually I have a couple
of subscribers on my channel that are
older than I am and I think that is the
I think that is the coolest thing I
think that is the very I think that is
very very cool that that makes me very
happy and actually a majority super
majority of the of my subscribers are my
viewers the subscribers I don't know if
I have access to that but a super
majority of my viewers are from overseas
international and a huge portion a huge
portion of my viewers are sometimes it's
sometimes it's f-words at 20 22 percent
are from India so that I think that is
very cool and a lot more are women
watching now when I first started it was
you could barely see it now it's up to I
think I've hit 15% at some weeks all
right so I digress
so here we go we got zero and you could
actually do this as nested where then if
it if it's not you can come out like
that
we'll deal with that later and really
sum this up because you want to have
this be as as efficient as possible and
the workflow so actually going to look
at workflow right now and we're gonna
look at building we're gonna do the
number triangle gonna have the number
triangle being next what I have next
we did even odd ooh actually here I want
to build this into a function let's do
this now
that's exactly what I have so we're
gonna build a and we need to learn about
return so we need we need to look we
need to look at return right now so
we're going to type this in even then we
take in a number and if x 2 equals zero
we need to look at this and we need to
look at then a compressed way to do this
return true so all right we were kind of
looking at how to speed this up so
return creates so right now I want to
show you this and then we're going to
show you a compressed way to do this to
do even then I'm gonna pass it this now
watch what happens nothing happened
I'm returning I'm creating something but
that's just creating it so I'm not
assigning it anywhere remember how we
did that if it created it and it
assigned it so now I'm gonna print this
out so this is true now this is a little
bit of extra double work if I switch
between single quotes and double quotes
also I can assign stuff to triple quotes
I am cute I'm a curious guy all right so
question I asked myself for 35 years
oh I gotcha okay so I let's plan on
dealing with the quotes next week
because that is a way so triple quotes
are typically utilized when you're
creating a function you know how we
typed in range like this and we got some
so we got something got some notes here
that's the documentation so if I come
over here comment this out ooh I'm sorry
guys no I mean to do that all right
so if I comment this out and I run and
if I run even I get my ex and I pass
that in and it's not gonna do anything
right now but then if I give it some
information one two three enter number
two be checked if even then once you one
two three all right so put that in a
memory and I call even if you spell even
right and I get the information I get
the how many variables do do i how many
arguments do I take and then was there
any documentation doc string right there
that's called a doc string and I get
this right here enter a number to be
checked if even so that's typically what
and then also three three quotation
marks are for double or excuse me
are for multi-line printing we can do it
we're gonna deal with all those things
with strings you got your new line you
got your tab think things like that and
then also if you really think about it
you have contraction
in Python excuse me in and print in
English and the reason why you got then
you have escape characters this is what
so like don't I'm having a heck of a
time typing today I apologize everybody
so for that to be able to work that's
why I was saying I suggest doing double
quotation marks I haven't I haven't
taught beginner stuff in a while I guess
it's been a couple months since I
started that other stuff so I apologize
I really emphasize want to enforce
reinforce using the double quotes
because so when you if you were to use
single quotes if you get into that habit
so when you do this you're gonna have a
nightmare but if you use double quotes
it goes through so I don't want to get
too far off I want to I want to get I
want to do the shoot let's get this all
right
I want us to do this for a second so now
we create and we got our numbers so
we're gonna go through and we're gonna
check this right and this works but boy
wait a minute what do we learn this
returns true so basically this is just
gonna kick out if I make X I make this
and I do this and I do this equals this
I'm gonna get a boolean so I don't need
to have this test here I just need to
[Music]
return this right so here I'll leave
this and we'll
let's come down here so death even X
returned x2 equals zero hmm just comment
that out let's run this boom so now
these are the type of things that we
need to be constantly thinking about can
I compress this can I can I make this
more fluid so I remand that's and that's
fine when you're starting out get it to
work get it to work learn something more
make the code better make it readable
make it flow better yes it will get
faster some people get hung up on faster
look old The Tortoise and the hare it is
a life their lifetimes of experiences
get it done make it work
so what then make it faster then make it
more efficient then you're gonna see
you're like oh my gosh I can I can move
that I can move that whole thing up
there
I can indent this that I can get this
step that if I check that at the
beginning this happens more than
anything I'm gonna move this to the top
those are those little bitty things
those little things that just save that
just save everything so any comparison
operator returns yes that that's that
that's what it returns every you get you
get binary a comparison it is either
true or false
it is either now we'd have not talked
about this then there are times so if I
wanted to make an odd one there's got to
be a way to do that right and guess what
there is return X excuse me why
- let's come over here so 1 is equal to
1 1 equal to 0 now there's 1 not equal
to 0 if you're anything like me you're
about to have a panic attack because I
hate I hate true and false questions
that's as well this is about the only
problem I really have that I have two
really excellent exclamation point 0 in
Python it's exclamation point 0 not
equal not equal so 1 is not 0 1 is not
equal to 0
true so if it's in the baby if it's not
0 its anything else so keep that in mind
because you can build a comparison that
you have a little bit of a problem with
but that's how we handle this so guess
what that's how we're gonna handle our
odd okay boom boom boom
so that is but yes every comparison
returns a boolean bingo that is exactly
right Y modulo 2 not equal to 0 and
that's your odd print odd 5 close that
out so we got true and true so 5 5 is
odd and 4 is even and guess what we pass
those in and there we go
so all right let's see where we are
today all right so I want to look at a
nested loop because those are very cool
and I think they teach a lot so let's do
this
for I in range five credit hi and we're
also going to learn about how to
suppress the new line with print okay so
I want how could I get a square and I
want four numbers I want four four
columns five columns five rows so I got
this five times so I call this let's
change it to row so we can just be
consistent in our temporary variable and
we can see it up in our head for row in
and we got to change this row so I got I
have my base I gonna go down I'm gonna
go down four times five times and now I
want to go over four times how do I do
this uh-huh print column arrange five
print column I mean let's see what this
does
oh that's not right okay so now there's
a no let's look real close and see what
print does it tells us a bunch of stuff
doesn't it it does so we got end that's
a new line so we need to look at this
for a second we need to go what is this
- if I print
this that's actually a newline character
in Python Python goes oh I know what
that is it's the equivalent of this I
want to show you because look right here
so I'm actually telling Python so this
is automatically slapped at the end of
every single print whatever print a new
line so I didn't pass in anything got a
new line that's why that works so now
I'm telling Python throw in a new line
and I know you're gonna put a new line
at the end of it anyway
alright so perfect that is exactly right
so now if I do column end and I change
it to a we need to do this first we
haven't blank
that's a lot of typing to get a blank so
that is still a string it is an empty
string and I know it's an empty string
because it has zero spaces I didn't
press any keys to get anything in
between it and type blank string so I'm
suppressing this right here okay all
right so I really don't need let's
experiment before we get rid of anything
before we get all crazy escape sequence
newline tab it's just the caret you
escape sequence escape characters that's
let's Det let's delve into that because
that's how you can also handle your
where we with our with our single quotes
and our quotes to have when you have a
problem and Python saying oh I know what
you're doing yeah we will get there so
now let's look let's look at this so
what am i doing okay so alright wait a
minute wait a minute okay I'm getting
I'm getting close I'm getting close I'm
getting close I'm getting close alright
now do I want a new one here is this my
flow nope because that's suppressing
that's supremum the same indention I'm
on the same instruction so I need to
back this out let's see this so we can
see this nice and clean and clear so I
need to back this out one loop 1 loop so
when I get done with that loop so I went
from an extreme of suppressing because I
want I want five rows of five columns so
I went from one line this way to one
line this way and I want it in between
so I want to balance this
ha so there we are I think this is a
perfect stopping point so Bo there there
we go
we got four minutes left I don't want to
start anything new but guys this was
super exciting I loved all of the good
interaction you guys you guys are
awesome so thank you so much for being
here and we're gonna be doing this for
this foreseeable future on Tuesdays at
10:00 10:00 Eastern 10:00 eastern time
and we'll be moving forward okay I know
what you're saying about copying and
pasting for airs if you're a more
seasoned you loot you lose the you lose
the pepper you you lose the practice you
lose the chance of making a mistake you
lose when you make a mistake you learn
so much I learned I I learned more from
debugging my own programs from the
garbage that I used to write and I don't
I
and also I've now become a much better
typer because I was just typing and
typing and typing and typing and also
you get out of we're running out of time
let's make next week's podcast awesome
together well I appreciate that
now you guys were very cool I appreciate
all the
[Music]
that is object-oriented yes we were we
will get there I like to build to that
okay you do you do see a jam yeah
it's just it if you know your if you
don't have to changing it because
especially I okay I had a young man just
working with a month or so ago and he
moves something but then all of it was
becoming frustrated because the
variables changed we had a different
function so then he started deleting
stuff and backspacing and he lost the
opportunity of learning to redo that
function reinforced learning when you're
typing this stuff over and over and over
again it's reinforced learning so and
especially you're always gonna have to
change some unless it's completely 100%
the same okay cop copy it I get that but
very rarely are you gonna but if you're
copying the exact same code it should be
a function that's also how you can know
that to you there's no if you have to
copy it you shouldn't need to be copying
it anyway right alright does that make
sense okay cool
all right I think we're right at time
though I'm gonna go ahead and shut it
down but I can't wait to see you guys
next week this was super awesome super
exciting for me I loved every second of
it
so you guys go check out my channel let
me know what you guys think and so you
guys can go and see where we are
planning on picking up next week and
we'll just go keep going through that
content and we'll be back here but you
guys are awesome and hope to see you
guys next week thanks Bob